ahora hablemos de economía en france 24
con nuestra periodista especializada en
el tema daniela blandón daniela
bienvenida y empecemos hablando sobre
las tensiones entre rusia y ucrania
porque ya occidente está pensando
sanciones de qué se trata maría clara
muy buenas noches de nuevo pues el
reconocimiento por parte del presidente
ruso vladimir putin de dos regiones
separatistas ucranianas como
independientes despertó de nuevo las
amenazas de occidente contra moscú ya el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
firmó una orden ejecutiva para prohibir
el comercio y la inversión entre sus
ciudadanos y esta región y la presidenta
de la comisión europea úrsula von der
leyen reveló algunos de los otros
detalles y dijo que si vladimir putin
inició una guerra responderán con la
herramienta más poderosa que tienen que
son las sanciones económicas y
financieras porque la economía según
ella es el punto débil de rusia se ha
dicho que una de las propuestas sería
sacar a rusia del sistema swift que es
la base del sistema financiero global y
lo usan 11 mil bancos en 200 países o
territorios para poder hacer
transferencias internacionales sin
embargo el fin de semana un alto
funcionario de la casa blanca lo
descartó por el momento el propósito de
esta noticia cuáles son los indicadores
del día es maría clara west street
estuvo cerrado el día de hoy pero las
tensiones entre rusia y occidente por
ucrania provocaron caídas en el resto de
las principales bolsas del mundo en
europa hubo pérdidas de alrededor del 2%
mientras tanto en américa latina hubo
resultados dispares pero también desde
luego con los ojos puestos sobre ucrania
y nos vamos a españa porque este país
decidió ampliar los horarios de los
bancos y también de las sucursales para
atender a las personas de la tercera
edad
claro mar y aclararía es que mire hace
dos semanas un adulto mayor recogió más
de 600.000 firmas en apoyo a una campaña
para que el gobierno obligará a los
bancos a no cerrar sus sucursales en
medio de su proceso de modernización
esto pensando en las personas que como
él no están familiarizados con la
tecnología el gobierno firmó entonces un
protocolo este lunes con los
representantes de los bancos en él se
comprometen a ampliar los horarios a
ofrecer asistencia preferente e
introducir cajeros con lenguaje
preferente para estas personas los
grandes bancos españoles marc y aclara
que son santander bbva caixabank y
sabadell redujeron su número de
empleados en 2000 en el 2021 en un 11% y
cerraron alrededor de tres mil
sucursales esto es casi una tercera
parte de su red y otra de las noticias
es que haití subió su salario mínimo si
el país lleva semanas de protestas
ciudadanas iniciadas por los
trabajadores de la confección que en su
mayoría exportan productos terminados a
eeuu como respuesta al primer ministro
ariel henry decretó un alza de hasta el
54 por ciento en el salario dependiendo
de la actividad económica por ejemplo
los empleados domésticos quedarán con un
salario en moneda local equivalente a
3,5 dólares por hora los trabajadores
textiles recibirán 685 dólares por hora
y los profesores y trabajadores de
supermercados se llevaron el mejor
aumento con 7,7 dólares por aunque todos
están muy lejos de las exigencias de los
sindicatos de 15 dólares por hora y por
eso fueron convocadas más
manifestaciones de esta semana ya
propósito de los incrementos el club de
los países más ricos reportó una
recuperación económica del 5 5% en 2021
de qué se trata así es después el
producto interno bruto de los 38 países
que conforman la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económicos o
la ucedé se recuperó así de una caída
del 4,6 por ciento en 2020 de ayuda a la
plantilla el mayor repunte en 2021 fue
para el reino unido con 7,5 por ciento
seguido de francia e italia aunque el
mayor repunte también obedece por lo
general a una caída más pronunciada el
año anterior y estos países en efecto
tuvieron un muy mal 2020 con respecto a
los otros miembros de la ocde este
organismo también actualizó a la baja
sus proyecciones para méxico que es uno
de los cuatro latinoamericanos en el
club ya no espera un crecimiento del 3,3
por ciento sino del 23 y advierte que no
ha superado los problemas que venían
antes de la pandemia y cerremos con la
cifra del día cuáles 43 mil 620 millones
de dólares anuales esto aporta la
industria del turismo australia que como
veíamos en los noticieros reabrió este
lunes sus fronteras a todos los turistas
vacunados tras casi dos años de cierre
gracias daniela por esta información y
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24
[Música]